vers me rencontrer ainsi que toute
l'équipe de la série le lundi 18
septembre à paris pour la projection en
avant-première de la fin de l'épopée
temporelle dans une salle de cinéma
exceptionnel va y avoir des questions
réponses des surprises le lien dans la
description pour prendre ton billet à
lundi est tout de suite l'épisode 9
temporaire nos héros sont en plein
tournoi dans le japon féodal de poussan
50 c'est le gagner ils pourront
récupérer la 3e reliques du docteur
simon ce qui leur permettra enfin de le
retrouver
malheureusement le pirate de la buse et
elliot le robot ont été éliminées et
tout le poids de la mission se retrouve
sur les épaules frêles de thomas parce
que oui
thomas est toujours dans l'aventuré ces
foules ou c'est moi qui dois me battre
contre ce mois je leur ai bien fait à ta
place un nom le règlement interdit les
femmes de participer
moi j'ai toujours été pour l'égalité
hommes femmes surtout si ça peut éviter
watson semafo et des amis j'ai perdu à
un combat et ça m'était jamais arrivé
pendant toute ma vie j'ai gagné 17 ans 2
victoires à 17 ans tu laissais pas du
tout c'est parce que je le connais il
valide
ça me rajeunit monde et toute façon on
pouvait pas prévoir tout ça ce n'est pas
de votre faute si ce qu'il arrive à
l'autre la sava elliott tenait pourquoi
ils disent ni d'agout quoi je crois que
notre sphère de métal est en train de
pleurer t'inquiète pas ça m'est arrivé
aussi une fois à ma naissance mais le
répétez pas non mais gignac ne veux pas
pleurer c'est une machine à café
techniquement je ne peux pas pleurer
mais je suis quand même triste
iris supplémentaires mais tetris de quoi
de plus avoir de tout y est en stock
grenon culture russe je suis triste
parce que c'est de ma faute si on ne
retrouvera jamais le docteur simon et
que thomas va mourir moi mais ça ça va
j'arrive à gérer avons confesse j'ai vu
mourir quand je suis arrivée dans votre
famille l'iris j'ai tout de suite
compris où était ma place dans la
cuisine autres gérard et muriel qui sont
le frigo et le lave vaisselle
une fois s'intéresser un petit personnel
n'est rien mais si on revenait sur le
fait que je vais mourir - le professeur
simon a toujours été gentil avec moi il
est le père que j'ai toujours voulu
avoir
alors que toi iris sa vraie fille tu ne
voulait pas de lui
c'est triste non aussi triste que moreno
quand il a disparu et qu'il m'a appelé
je me suis dit ça y est c'est mon heure
de gloire
je vais le retrouver et il me dira merci
fils temps absolu
je suis désolé a tu sais pas personne
est désolé de savoir que je vais mourir
écoutez moi personne ne va mourir et on
va gagner ce tournoi hockey et puis on
va récupérer la dernière reliques et
retrouver mon père et ça c'est grâce à
toi il n'ya pas parce que tu es paca
robot maintenant on tire
voilà un des amis merci fin du mode
tristesse début du mode reprise de
confiance en soi
je suis content d'apprendre que je veux
pas mourir et j'ai hâte de savoir
comment c'est possible du coup thomas si
tu utilises tu as force passe à ce
samouraï tu vas mourir
ok c'est pas du tout ce que je l'entends
la seule façon pour toi de gagner le
match
c'est de pousser le samouraï hors du
ring au thon
je sais faire ça moore c'est pour ça
qu'il faut que tu t'entraînes elle genre
beaucoup le match et dans cinq minutes
oui j'apprends vite oui j'ai fini sniper
elite 400 les tutos mais quand même on
peut voyager dans le temps je vous
rappelle on peut passer des heures à
s'entraîner où on veut et quand on veut
ok donc la question c'est où et quand
apprendre à pousser quelqu'un très fort
quelqu'un de dos ça m'arrange à
quelqu'un qu'il hérite qu'ont tous des
centaines de fois sans ressentir de
culpabilité
bon tu as vu comment j'ai fait thomas à
toi maintenant elliot on recommence
si thomas hocquet jvg ripper pas tomber
ça fait essayer de vote au sénat ce
n'est pas très gentil coup ça ni le
chômage dans le faille des caisses
[Musique]
quelle sensation agréable ah ouais c'est
cool hein de pousser et de l'air d'un
balcon c'est qu'ils veulent c'est à bah
oui c'est vrai tu veux pas le connais
c'est la première fois que le petit
bonhomme c'est comme ça ce sera pour moi
quand je vois quelques à près d'une
fenêtre je le pousse
c'est dans ma nature non on va éviter de
s'approcher trop près du bord alors
elliot on repart en arrière thomas soit
aime surtout applique avec ça si tu
marques
[Musique]
mais c'est ok
1 2 3 tu t'améliores par mounir tour et
yonne
[Musique]
ouais ok mais
c'est bizarre il ya bien un truc nouveau
là c'est impossible
chaque fois qu'on remonte dans le temps
la réalité relais ma carrière tourne ou
poussières samouraï martin hockey au
revoir le savoir j'ai l'impression qu'il
sait qu'on le pousse à chaque fois c'est
vraiment bizarre on recommence thomas
qui doit être prêt ok ça alors il plus
c'est anormal ou hitler a disparu dans
la pièce où tu dégages petit bonhomme à
moustache on n'a plus personne à pousser
20 à l'entraînement et l'at on retourne
à notre tournoi
ok je pense que je me sens prêt je peux
le pousser ce parti pour la terreur
hagi mohamud est la fierté de la nation
d'entre eux thomas juste thomas les
adversaires je salue et
mais le gagne ok je suis prêt je vais te
pousse le drame j'y vais
[Applaudissements]
son adversaire non pas seulement
rebondir contre lui contrairement à
hitler le samouraï est très lourd 90 kg
de muscles lespinard mais c'est plus dur
de gourdes tu me donnes samouraï a même
pas bougé c'est tout la charge thomas
n'a pas suffi et maintenance et takeshi
qui sont lentement son katana une sens
proche de thomas qui défie j'ai le coeur
il semblerait que thomas sont reproduits
par terre et sur le côté et en
opposition aux pétales et l'avant sa
main près de son visage
il sort son pause
d où il est nommé à sa gauche pour
l'aude était
bottieau qu'est ce que je vois là non
ici c'est bien voulu rink écoles de
saint pantaléon vous souhaitez ajouter
celle là non ça va avec cette histoire
c'est trop triste et terriblement
gênante je propose qu'on ne dise pas à
sa mère comment il est mort on dira
qu'il est tombé d'une falaise en jouant
à pokémon de ses plus nobles
adieu petit matelot chétif herbert ben
que se passe-t-il takeshi legrand
samouraï effet j'ai son katana à la main
il ne donne pas le coup de grâce aux
attendez attendez je crois qu'il va dire
quelque chose
ce n'est pas un combattant
c'est un enfant j'ai déshonoré mon clan
home battant contre lui je ne mérite pas
de vivre
aulas takeshi retourne la lame contre
lui
ces boyaux sont au sol
je ne sais pas
quoi une défaite par hara kiri
comme on en a
déjà lus n'est ce pas mais tout à fait
c'est vrai que dans notre pays on ne se
suicide pas avec le dos de la cuillère
le dollar proche de la route lancé
stroll
l'actif du mont fuji
c'est une canne maléfique porte-clés en
hausse sauf s'il veut également se
suicider pour laver son honneur d'avoir
dernière d'une manière aussi honteuse
alors qu'on apprenait le gagnant du tour
j'ai pas compris comment tu as a battu
laval utiliser la pression psychologique
je suis pas seulement un physique vous
savez je suis aussi un fin stratège donc
c'était une ruse et ses habitudes avant
c'était pour de faux maths ça sent le
rapide un ton pantalon à pattes désolé
je voulais que ce soit crédible alors
oui j'ai utilisé mon urine pour faire
transparaître la peur ça s'appelle
latine et madame le plus important est
qu'il ait gagné
bon allons retrouver le second pour
récupérer la relique
[Musique]
l'étranger vous savez gagner le grand
tournoi avec courage je ne peux pas dire
ça
vous avez gagné quoi tient la route ah
oui c'est plus la renault quand c'est
strahl confie sarah entre les scruter
caché goûteront pas rien échangez votre
pantalon la drache ça sent juste et
c'est merci m et meynard ont dit que
c'est une dague de petite taille mais
d'une incroyable finesse
oui c'est le couteau de la cuisine je le
reconnais le docteur simon l'utilisait
pour couper les légumes
il s'appelle comment ce couteau raymond
fabris c'est un couteau thomas
les objets n'ont pas de prénom non mais
c'est pas que ça c'est le couteau que je
lui offert pour la fête des pères quand
j'avais 10 ans à 10 ans j'étais encore
avec ma première femme
non mais la première reliques c'était un
cadeau de mon père la deuxième aussi et
celle là c'est un cadeau que j'ai fait à
mon père si par hasard tu es sûr c'est
pas juste des objets qu'il a pris au
hasard chez lui mais non ça veut dire
qu'il essaie de me faire passer un
message ça veut dire qu'ils pensent à
moi et qui compte sur moi pour le
retrouver
oui enfin je te rappelle qu'elle m'a
appelé moi à la base comme un père qui
demande de l'aide à son fils oui était
venu me retrouver après il savait que
j'allais faire ça et que j'allais
retrouver ces reliques et savez pour moi
aussi ah non non non ils savaient pas
pour toi tu es un accident par courtois
merci ça fait toujours plus et vous
choque toujours dans mon problème ah oui
pardon
elliott qu'est ce qu'on fait je fais
yonne les coordonnées des reliques
[Musique]
c'est bon j'ai décoder de nouvelles
coordonnées temporel aux médias on va au
cette époque et ce lieu ne vont pas vous
plaire au tampon réalisation immédiate
la lame et où nos héros vont ils encore
atterrir
que va-t-il leur arrivée pour le savoir
il va falloir acheter le dernier épisode
pour la modique somme de 99 euros un
parent dont il sera gratuit comme les
autres c'est une bonne nouvelle
rendez vous pour la fin de l'épopée
temporel
merci d'avoir écouté l'avant dernier
épisode de l'épopée temporel saison une
n'hésite pas à ta bonnet et à mettre un
pouce en l'air et à la semaine prochaine
pour la fin de la saison